you have four four four four four and
four and using all four fours you have
to create using the mathematical
operators as many numbers as you can so
the way that we start this normally if
we're doing level one for Falls will be
all the you're allowed to use is
addition subtraction multiplication and
division
well let's start at naught and we're
going to link it to one and we added two
so it was not how do you get four fours
tweaked we'll north it's kind of easy
you can go four minus four plus four
minus four that's not brilliant
we've got naught okay let's at the four
falls again to equal one well we could
do 4/4
now that's one plus four minus four or
we could have done four divided by four
divided by four divided by four which is
1 divided by 1 which is 1 again that's
one there are also different ways and
they get a little bit more complicated
and we can give you two and we can carry
on upwards how far ten a hundred a
thousand I'm going to show you today
Brady your mind will be blown I will
prove the full Falls all the way up to
infinity you can make every one book you
can make every number up to infinity
it's a fantastic little proof and we're
going to get next we need to actually be
really clarifying the operator sir we
can get up to 10 just with these plus
minus multiplication and division to get
up to 20 we need to introduce some other
things what we need to introduce is
concatenation which means that just like
we've got 4 4 4 4 we can bring them
together so we can actually bring them
together and consider that say 44 we
introduce a decimal point so one of
these could be 0.4 and we introduce the
factorial which means it's 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 and also we need the
square root
so square roots for w-2 you might think
well that's spoiling this other this was
a beautiful simple puzzle but actually
factorial concatenation vessel and
square roots are really basic they're
kind of in our basic armory so I think
that's fine well how far can we do with
all of these we can definitely get up
all the way to 50 higher than 60 we get
up pretty high we get up to 100 but in
fact we need to start introducing other
ones and I'll shade someone one of the
ones that doesn't work with all these is
say 99 I'm going to show you how to do
99 99 there are different ways to do
this but this is the one I quite like it
all depends which is an assembly you're
going to do 4 over 4 as a percentage is
a hundred minus 1 is 99 so that's quite
a clever way and the good fun thing
about the four fours which just say
you're bored on a plane or a train you
can just start at the beginning and then
just go up and if you've got a long-haul
flight you might be able to up to 500 or
something some purists might disagree
and say this is really ugly and prefer
something else some people introduce
things like the triangle number of or
there's lots of combinatorial symbols
EVOO you know 4 to 4 or full factorial
choose 4 but already with the operations
that I've mentioned here well we have
pretty much everything we need the only
other one that we need to get up to
infinity is log and log is a pretty
simple thing mathematically speaking do
you mean long term the natural log or
all different types of locks we're going
to get there
because actually the logs that we need
is log base 4 cool I'm cool that's it
before and we're also going to use a log
base 1/2
there's your breeze refresher on what a
log is ok so if a equals B to the C then
C log base B of A equals C so that's
basically the same thing let's put some
numbers in because we're going to be
doing log 4 so 4 is equal to 4 to the 1
okay
it's 4 to 1
for so the log base 4 of 4 is 1/16 is 4
squared so the log base 4 of 16 equals
264 equals 4 cubed so log base 4 before
equals 3 but can you see there's a
pattern here basically log to base 4 of
4 to the N equals n n doesn't have to be
a whole number so the square root of n
is the same thing as n to the half
so let's translate that here we've got
log to base 4 of the square root of 4
which is actually log base 4 of 4 to the
1/2 equals 1/2 and let's do the square
root of the square root of n which is
the same thing as n to the 1/2 times 1/2
which is the same thing as n to the
quarter we get log base 4 of square root
of the square root of 4 equals log the
base 4 equals 1/4
now you're going to carry on because
although I say log base 4 square root
the square root the square root of 4
equals logs to base 2 of 4 becomes 1 x
equals 1/8 so we are half the way there
to proving the fall 4 to infinity
because what was actually done we've got
two fours we know that this expression
here we know log 4 the square root of 4
is half log thought the square root of
the square root of 4 is 1/4 so we know
that just using two fours we can get the
Hartness to having sequence which goes
half quarter aches so we've got two
fours left and let's see how we can get
there another bit of paper we're going
to do all on this next bit of paper we
had log 4 of 4 to the N is n it's
actually the same whatever we have here
that would be the same log 1/2 1/2 to
the N equals n right and so let us now
try to find the log base 1/2
of these things here what I'm going to
do the answer is always log base 1/2 of
1/2 that's 1 log base 1/2 of 1/4
ok we get to fourth to do that is the
same thing as log base 1/2 of 1/2
squared which equals to log base 1/2 of
an X is log base 1/2 of 1/2 cubes which
equals 3 so we know that two fools goes
into here and then here in a here we
just need to find a way of expressing
log base 1/2 with poofles so we need to
find a way of dressing 1/2 in two fours
but half is obviously 2 over 4 but that
same thing as root 4 over 4 so here we
can say that log to the base root 4 over
4 of log 4 root 2 is 1 because that is
1/2 and that's log 1/2 and so that's 1
so you use all four all of them so I've
got all 4 Falls earlier I showed you how
you can use a full force to make one in
a very very simple way you pull divided
by 4 plus 4 minus 4 is 1 but you can
also do it here log to the root 4 over 4
of long to the base full of root 4 is 1
but log to the base 4 over 4 of log base
4 on the square root of the square root
of 4 equals 2 so this will expand out
and there are many square roots times
you put there is equal to the number so
you think is like what you just give you
put a billion square roots times where
you get do you yeah if you have a bit of
paper big enough to write log root 4
over 4 of log for the
square root the square root the square
root so much that you have a billion
square root signs of square root for
what including everything there a
billion square root sign that would
equal a billion before Falls is a puzzle
that was first written down in the late
nineteenth century and you see very
clearly in 1890 there's a boom of this
puzzle then in like the 1930s there's
another boom Paul Dirac has a go at it
Paul Dirac who famously loved
mathematical puzzles basically beats a
puzzle completely defeats the puzzle for
it's this idea how high can you go were
the operators that you're going to need
and he just says well with just logs and
a square root I can bust this it's
broken I can follow it all the way to
infinity you can get is an eccentricity
of one well actually it's no longer to
let's end it's a parabola and the
shortest you can get is an eccentricity
of zero so X into Z means away from the
circle